he is a three-time Super Bowl champion
from the New England Patriots most
career postseason sacks in NFL history
with 16 he is willing McGinnis salary
Willie great to chat with you willing
McGinest here on the Rich Eisen show how
do you term yourself what would
adjectives would you use to describe
your feelings that tom brady is now a
Tampa Bay Buccaneer Willie I'm excited
for Tom I'm definitely excited for Tom
you know I was I was selfishly wanting
him to retire as a patriot of course a
lot of us didn't get the opportunity to
do that rich very few I think Troy Brown
Tedy Bruschi the guys from the original
clan didn't really get that opportunity
but you know things happen it's a new
adventure for Tom I'm excited for Matt
I'm happy for them and we'll see what
happens man it's going to be interesting
so obviously your circumstance is
different from Tom's but what what can
you tell Brady about putting on a
different uniform for the first time
like when you grab that Browns helmet
and Browns uniform for the turf first
time Willie what do you think is gonna
go through his head when he does that
for Tampa well I think the one thing
that's gonna happen is there's going to
be a standard as soon as he walks
through the door everybody is going to
expect a certain standard if you know
Tom and you know the way he's worked in
the last 20 years and his expectations
his work ethic all the different
characteristics about him going into a
different building everybody might not
initially be on the same page and as a
player coming from somewhere like that
people are going to want to know
everything about what it takes to be a
champion how do you guys continuously
and consistently play at a high level
all the tricks all the different things
and I think that that's a great that's a
great thing one thing that I found with
myself when I went to Cleveland I didn't
want to always say you got to do it like
this fellas because we did it like this
in New England I can turn guys off what
I wanted to do was lead by example and
just lead through my action
and I think Tom's going to be the same
way he's never going to discuss the past
he doesn't do that now in New England
about previous Championships or games or
any of that unless it's relevant to
something that's about to happen now
he's going to focus on the future but
he's just going to lead the way with his
actions on how to do certain things and
if guys inquire or talk or one of those
certain things he'll probably have those
conversations but I think the standard
for the organisation is going to be
lifted we already see that with ticket
sales and expectations people are now
talking superbowl which we hadn't heard
there and I don't know how many years
the work you know God's going to have to
work because they're going to see it
from him for guy going into his 21st
years working harder then God's in their
third and fourth year that's going to be
a problem - Tom and you know everybody
else so you're going to see the
difference in a lot of different things
and it's a good thing rich Willie
McGinest my my compadre and friend from
NFL Network joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show I want to get into the why a
little bit with you Willie
I had Tom Curren of NBC Sports Boston
who's been covering the team from
probably even back in your day as well I
had him on the show
just hours after Tom Brady put out on
the Instagram on his Instagram post that
he was leaving and then the statement
from Bill Belichick that read at the
very end sometimes in life it takes some
time to pass before truly appreciating
something or someone but that has not
been the case with Tom he is a special
person in the greatest quarterback of
all time Tom Curren said that somebody
from Brady's camp who he was talking to
said that if Belichick actually said
that more in real time that Brady might
still be a patriot potentially how does
that land with you Willie that makes
that makes sense I mean I mean you know
Bill has a certain way about him and how
he communicates and deals with people
and everybody is different I think
that's what makes the world go around
everybody is different nobody's the same
and you know sometimes players need to
hear that more or um need to experience
that a little bit more I think when
you're in the moment you hate to you
don't
to go back and reminisce and talk about
certain things or whatever the case may
be because you want to continuously find
that grind and find that edge but when
you get to a certain point in any type
of relationship I think it's okay to
tell a player or a coach for that matter
hey man you did a great job you're doing
well I appreciate you you know the
things that people exchange and talk and
I just think that things have been so
the same for so long sometimes people
get used to doing that whether it's a
coach or a player and you forget some
things like the little things matter and
I'm not necessarily sure that because
you know maybe Belichick didn't tell
Brady everyday how much he appreciates
them and loves them and you know thank
him for for all the opportunities he's
put him in and vice versa that's the
reason why it's God I think there's
other things that also played into that
but you know in any type of marriage any
type of relationship sometimes things
run its course
and you got to find different ways to
keep that relationship ignited and you
know I just think that in this situation
Brady wanted to be there long term I
don't think that was an option you know
it didn't happen a year ago or whatever
and Brady probably came to a point where
he said you know what maybe I need to go
and venture out and try something
different new atmosphere new coaching
style new you know new team and just to
see what it feels like and I think
that's normal and and in life and
anything so then why you know cuz again
you know Robert Kraft said that if Brady
wanted to be a patriot he would then why
if Tom didn't want to stay there long
term why didn't it happen I mean is it
is it time that Belichick you think
thought like I need to try something
else let's move on we did this making
sure he would retire as a patriot age 42
and if he wants to keep playing we got
to figure something else out or what can
you
I mean we never saw offer you know when
we were watching this whole thing
happened there was never an offer not to
my knowledge or you know from from just
being a spectator and you know you got a
there's two sides when you negotiate and
you're trying to either stay or you're
trying to keep a player and I know a lot
of times that you know in my situation I
didn't get a offer because they didn't
want to disrespect me or want me to feel
like you know that wasn't you know
something that I was going to want kind
of how it happened with Tyler when he
left with the Patriots and it becomes a
big thing and blows up and sometimes
when you're used to dealing with
somebody for so long
you feel like any you could just talk it
out make some happen you know have a
have initial agreement you know verbally
or whatever and you know it'll happen
because you've dealt with each other so
long with Brady and his representation
so like I said there you know I wasn't
in the room with those conversations I
just know if if things far as a contract
probably would have been out there we
would have heard about it I'm sure that
they wanted Brady to stay I'm not sure
for how long I think that's that's
pretty pretty interesting and that's
important you know part I know Brady it
was tough and emotional for him to pick
up and leave somewhere he's been for 20
years you know he's made history and
that history will never be duplicated in
New England so I mean it was tough on
both sides but I think you know if they
came together and had those
conversations it was a mutual
understanding that they were part ways
and go each other's way I don't think
you could put everything on one side
yeah I don't think by any reporting Ian
Rapoport told me yesterday on the air
live before you know we switched chairs
Willie
on the Wednesday coverage that the
Patriots did never did put something on
the table that they wanted to hear from
Tom first that he wanted to stay and
instead obviously we all know we all
know what happened
what do you think Willie McGinest Iran
the Rich Eisen show what do you make of
the report that Bella cheque was left a
little shocked by Brady saying I'm
leaving
would that does that make sense to you
I'm not sure I mean maybe you know
nobody expected you know in patriot
country for that to happen everybody
including myself thought that the
Patriots would have the first shot at
you know signing Brady back now remember
he's an unrestricted free agent right so
you know with all these different free
agents teams have to submit an offer or
to say hey this is what we think this is
what we want to do you know the charges
did it
the bugs did it I'm sure there's other
teams that did it with Brady a door
offer out there we kind of knew what
those numbers were you know and you know
as a coach if you've been with somebody
for so long like I said you're kind of
used to the same routine maybe you are a
little surprised if you think this
player probably going to leave but I
would be shocked to say he was totally
surprised Bill Belichick is always he's
always prepared
I wouldn't say prepared for almost
everything because you never know you
know there's no rulebook for certain
things that happen in the league and you
know certain situations that come up but
he's pretty prepared and pretty
calculated he's a smart guy one of the
smartest guys out even outside of
football I've ever met
Matt so you know it's a little bit of a
shock to all of us initially but when
you saw that he was content when tom was
content with moving on and you know he
was kind of excited by the possibilities
of what was out there then it kind of
became a reality that he could leave
Ryan he you know he did and then what do
you think Bella checks knowing him
unless you've spoken here have you
spoken to bill or Tom okay bill okay but
you have spoken to Tom we tax of course
we text we text when it's not going on
you know okay and and he must be over
the moon right ecstatic excited yes he's
excited for the for the new opportunity
um isn't he no he's going to a
competitive
conference he has a lot of respect for
Drew Brees and that Ryan and in teddy
bridgewater he know there's those are
good teams and if you know anything
about Tom which I know you do you know a
lot about them rich he's very
competitive oh yeah he loves a challenge
and that's what drives them that's what
was driven him his whole career
people are telling him what he couldn't
do people say it when he turned 38 and
40 what he couldn't do and all he's done
is gone and win championships and and
MVP so this is another chapter in his
life and his family's life in his
football life and he's uh he's excited
he's excited and I don't know how deep
you got into it with him I imagine
Ariane's had something to do with it
right I mean what what do you what do
you glean excited him about Tampa well I
think when you look when you look at the
personnel Tom wants to win I mean this
is not like a five-year rebuild right
saying he wanted to also go somewhere
where there was talent you know
receivers the offensive line there's
young X players on the staff that Brady
played against that he can relate to
amazing aryans has a great personality
he's he's he's he's the polar opposite
of what you know what dill is which is
fine you know he's the offensive minded
coach so I'm thinking when they scheme
in a game plan would bar and left for
which all those things are coming to
play
Brady's IQ was very very high so I think
Bruce Arians
respects that and Byron definitely
understands it knows that Brady scene
and play more football than the embarass
you know and I don't know in a few years
so well we'll see how that plays out but
there's a lot other pieces you know
defensively table bowls they got a lot
of confidence in him and that defense
yeah and seeing them make strides from
last year and they're just a couple of
pieces away I mean we talked about the
receivers and all that but you know I'm
sure other players are going to want to
come to Tampa or they're going to draft
or do whatever they can to put the
pieces needed around Tom to make sure
he's successful I'm gonna ask you sports
talk radio
a question that's gonna put you on the
spot Willie I'm gonna do it I'm just
giving that heads up wow you can handle
it
okay next three years I'll give you a
choice of one who wins the championship
more likely that wins a championship
first Brady or Belichick you're in time
I'm gonna say both I'm gonna say both
because you didn't you didn't specify
championship possibly win a championship
bridge won an AFC won an NFC how about
that yeah you know it's like Tom saying
I plead the fifth it's pretty much what
he's saying right there that's bits it
sounded like that's the fair there you
go one AFC one in a seat could possibly
happen well I in all you know honesty
Belichick has got that high IQ too right
he's that competitive sob - he is a guy
who is hearing all this and I don't
think there's enough thumbtacks
available or a billable a bulletin board
large enough for him to attack up for
all the players that are still there
I'm championship quality players that
are still there what do you think his
plan for replacing Brady is what do you
think the plan B is Willie before I let
you know I think you can replace a Tom
Brady I'm going to find a quarterback
that suits the system and what you're
trying to do
well the question is is it Stidham is he
really gonna go and just take the tape
lumps like start taking lumps right now
in growing pains or does he get somebody
that can actually get a fountain of
youth or a second chance himself cam
Andy Dalton Jameis like that which
direction do you think he might go in I
think it could be any of those options I
think that Bill's gonna bring in a guy
one that's gonna take care of the
football that's why I kind of don't
think it'll be a guy like Jameis Winston
too many turnovers and that's important
in New England taking care of the
football it's got to be somebody who's
smart who's tough
whose accurate and you know who can
bring that leadership it can't be a
selfish guy to come into that locker
room because that's not how the Patriots
are built and that's not what they've
they've been able you know to do in the
last few you know the last I don't know
how many years it's been about team
first it could possibly be a guy in the
draft Joe Thomas mentioned yesterday on
air about you know jaylen hurts a guy
like that if Bill sees this game
changing a little bit why not bring in
somebody that can throw and move the
hockey like a Russell Wilson or a Lamar
Jackson you know or somebody like that
and bring in a veteran for a couple of
years to you know just to hold it down
as far as did him I'm not sure if I've
seen enough from him enough playing time
to say he's the guy or he has that
experience I know a lot of people talk
you know really well really good about
them but I just haven't seen enough so I
don't know if he's ready and the
expectation is not just to get by in New
England you know it's it's it's
Championships it's always been
championships whether we talked about it
or not so it's they're not going to be
content with just bringing in somebody
and just you know throwing it out there
it's gonna be somebody that knows and is
willing to work and win and and graph
the system and play at a high level will
you the man thinks the call take care of
yourself your family be healthy you safe
you're too rich I appreciate right back
at you right back at you that's Willie
McGinest how about that one what ago
when jaylen hurts you take him yeah
buddy does uh does Bill know anybody
that might have coached jaylen he we
could call him up chitchat with I think
you might know a guy I'm telling it's a
great one I'd be all over that jaylen
hurts in the second or third round oh
don't no doubt you could sit there take
care of your first-round pick and then
hope you know that he's still there in
your second round
we'll move up to get him I love that kid
you know how I feel about him it's a
good one Super Bowls a good one I don't
know if we'll he's just picking that out
of thin air either